Dr. Thomas is a free author of cancer as a metabolic disease promotes the ketogenic diet and at time do it mean restriction to not feed cancer.
He has coined the term metabolic ecology thoughts on this approach seems he has excellent results and affects cancer cells and others.
So yes, so understand ketogenic diet again is something that's your strongly restricted any glucose in the body and that's the balance of, you know, looking at getting a glucometer and measuring your glucose.
Now in if you're getting truly into ketosis and your goal is to get into ketosis you can't just use a glucose monitor you have to use a ketone monitor that gets a little trickier and there's a little bit of a learning curve to learn how to measure that and to get yourself into ketosis if that is a person's goal.
Most practitioners, though believe like I do that it's not even necessary to get into ketosis really if you could get your blood glucose down below 80 you can do the same thing is what he is doing.
Matter fact there's some research that's going on right now through a group that I follow that is using Dr. Thomas as a member in the research group and that's what they are finding so even under his guidance they are actually finding you get the exact same benefits is trying to get into ketosis is just getting the glucose levels down.
Now understand it can be hard to do I mean it is very difficult to stay on a ketogenic diet and it is even more difficult to truly stay in ketosis and most people end up giving up the younger you are the easier it is to do that as we age it's even more difficult to truly get into ketosis.
And it can be difficult as we've talked about these zoom calls even eating a pretty perfect diet many times it's hard to get your glucose levels down below 100 for some people because glucose is not just a product of your diet it's a product of your cell membranes and it's a product of your pancreas.
So there's a lot of different pieces to the puzzle I've had over the years I've had diabetic patients that would go on a full ketogenic diet and they still there it was I was just mind boggled that it's not eating any glucose and any carbohydrates whatsoever and we couldn't care glucose levels below 150.
So it was like gosh it's more complex of that now the younger a person is trying to do that it's a little bit easier to do.
Should I be taking glutamate as a supplement no absolutely not it's really a glutamate restriction that you want to do so glutamate can feed cancer remember so you don't want to take glutamate as a supplement.
And especially it's even more important not to take glutamate as a supplement if you're if you're have colon or colorectal cancer.
And the epitelial cells in your colon prefer gluten-y or rectal cation.